most people don't allocate their time
well if you still have your level three
job you can still spend your other hours
of the day learning whatever the new
thing that you're passionate about is
and usually if you spend the other hours
of the day doing that you're going to
quickly level up your skill faster than
you are on the main skill because you're
not really investing in yourself on that
side and so wherever you're attention
goes money will follow you invest on
that new thing until eventually maybe
you're level two or level three of that
thing and then all of a sudden you can
make a horizontal swap in income without
having to sacrifice lifestyle